der postbote konnte heute nicht nur um
pakete abzuholen
er beschwert sich auch über die viele
arbeit über 100 pakete jeden tag da muss
der chef selbst mit anpacken
die pakete enthalten lebensmittel
reserven für die große krise zukünftig
wird ein laster nur für sie kommen läuft
das geschäft gut dann haben die menschen
besonders viel angst vor einer krise
das ist schon so von dem her
die merken schon lenz wenn die leute
sich gedanken machen das ist und die
entwicklung geht auch in dieser stetig
die geht aufwärts
philipp nato sucht dringend
aushilfskräfte
sein kollege ist heute nicht da 14
stunden tage seit zwei wochen notvorräte
für menschen die angst davor haben dass
die nahrungsmittel einmal knapp werden
ein diskretes geschäft das ist nicht für
das bankgeschäft
man muss nicht wissen ist dass der
nachbar weiß wie viel geld man auf dem
konto hat und das genau dasselbe man
will nicht dass der nachbar weiß wie
viel nahrung ich im notfall im keller ab
weil wenn es nichts mehr gibt also es
gibt nicht menschliches als dass man
sich dann auch etwas wo man weiß wo es
deshalb dürfen die pakete nicht mit dem
firmennamen beschriftet sein
dieses paket soll für eine person 30
tage reichen
zehn jahre ist es haltbar und enthält
zum beispiel weizenmehl sojabohnen
vollmilchpulver 20.000 kalorien zum
überleben in der krise
und genau darauf bereitet er sich vor
walter dold ist rapper das wort leitet
sich vom englischen up to be prepared
vorbereitet sein
in seine seminare kommen immer mehr
menschen um vorbereitet zu sein
zum beispiel mit solchen flucht
rucksäcken wenn ich aber jetzt von zu
hause weg gehen muss das heißt also wenn
ich nicht mehr zurückgehen kann wenn man
zuhause untergehen sollte egal durch
lars brandt marodierende gruppen egal
was dann wäre der flucht rucksack der
tatsächliche große flucht rucksack der
bei mir immer parat steht also immer
bereit steht
wer zu hause bleiben kann sollte sich
dort so eine monatsration anlegen
außerdem rät er ein zweites sicherheits
depot vorzubereiten
diese tonne habe ich wenn ich jetzt als
pram einen so genannten sicheren ort
auslagern
das heißt also ich habe nochmal irgendwo
eine unterkunft bei bekannten bei
freunden oder der berghütte in dem ich
jetzt immer wo ich jetzt ein
lebensmittel vorrat für eine bestimmte
zeit deponieren möchte dann kann ich das
mit diesem gefäß durch dieses gefäß kann
ich als sagen gut das ist jetzt meine
monats zone bei einem ausfall der
stromversorgung versiegt auch irgendwann
das leitungswasser
deshalb gibt er den tipp sich einen
wasserfilter anzuschaffen um vereintes
fluss wasser zu filtern
erst dann kann er den kaffee auch
genießen
technisches equipment hat auch die
schweizer firma im angebot ein radio für
note durchsagen des katastrophenschutzes
die geschäfte laufen so gut dass die
schweizer diesen zweiten
vertriebsstandort in süddeutschland
eröffnet haben
die kompakteste energie-versorgung
steckt in diesem weizen regel die
packung reicht für zwei tage und passt
in jeden flucht rucksack
rocken aber sehr kalorienhaltig
hochkalorische das ist für den notfall
ist das ideal
sie wollen keine panikmache sie kennen
ihre kunden und für die meisten ängste
haben sie das passende sortiment im
angebot
vor sechs jahren wurden laut ausgelacht
und dann kommt mir gut wo das ein
bisschen leiser und wenn wir jetzt was
sorgen dann wird nur noch zugehört und
nicht mehr wachsen gemacht die
finanzkrise das ende des maya-kalenders
fukushima jedes mal gibt es mehr
bestellungen aber die aktuelle notfall
liste der deutschen regierung hat ihnen
den größten auftrag der firmengeschichte
beschert